we've long had our theories about why  Zayn Malik left one direction but were  finally hearing from the man himself his  reason though is unexpected to say the  least  Zayn tells glamour and alien told him to  leave 1d I spoke to him in a dream he  says that's right an alien is to blame  for the end of the fad five hiding the  23 year old also opens up to the mag  about his firsts his first crush  mary-kate and Ashley Olsen the first  thing he does before any performance is  quote pay homage to Bob Marley and while  he's currently linked to gigi hadid the  first person he calls or texts in the  morning is his mum the pillow-talk  singer is about to embark on his first  major solo tour for the album mind of  mine and dare we say it's going to be  out of this world  and it is our zone